[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanut
peanuts I have a sister and she is 10
years younger than me and apparently was
raised by her best friends
she has no fear of them I mean I'm
scared my dad's going to show up tonight
last week Naper gazi came out with a
brand new comedy special on Prime video
titled hello world this is special
number five for Nate bargatsi and the
first one to be released not on Netflix
according to their description Nate
delivers his family-friendly take in a
variety of topics including
disadvantages of being the firstborn the
challenges of playing golf with your
wife and what happens when a bald eagle
touches your head after watching hello
world myself last week I asked 183 000
comedy fans for their thoughts on the
new special the top comment comes from
Mike B who said Being older now and
having been in marriage for longer than
I can remember with kids it was funny
and relatable for me I enjoyed the hell
out of it I miss being young your 20s
are great you're down for whatever
your friends call you they're like do
you want to go you're like I'll go you
don't even know where you're going
your 30s come and you're like where are
we going
how late are they open is it loud
I am going to drive separate
now technically there's still some
aparazzi fans that haven't even got the
chance to watch Hello World yet do some
sort of streaming issue with Amazon
Prime video Jim said Prime video doesn't
even show me this in Australia Victor
said still waiting here in Canada and
another fan commented it's not available
in Canada I wish I could support him
Naper gotzi posted this image on
Instagram on Tuesday with the caption
reading apologies again to everyone
trying to watch Hello World outside the
US and UK but it'll be available
worldwide on February 17th so please
hang tight thank you for your patience
the house I was born into my parents
were 23 when I was born and they rented
a home and then we just I just talked to
them about this and they said the front
door of their home was a sliding glass
door
and I was like that doesn't make sense
like how do you even lock it you can
only lock those with a pole
so how do you lock it and then you know
and I asked them I asked him what I'm
sure you are thinking I was like are you
sure you did not live in this home
backwards
as many of you already know all of
neighbor got these specials have been
clean comedy meaning there's no swearing
no dirty premises throughout the entire
show which our audience was honestly
pretty split on some people really liked
it and some people did not Josh said
clean comedy is not my favorite but it's
good solid work Nate God knows there's
some comedians out there that are dirty
and about as funny as a cancer diagnosis
Nolan O'Reilly said I never care for
clean comedy because I always felt like
people are holding something back what I
love about Nate is that his stuff is so
original that doesn't feel clean I'm
never thinking a joke could have been
more funny with profanity his the
ability to make such smart and original
takes while still convincing the
audience that he's dumb which I think is
brilliant I consider him at the top tier
of Comedy right now for this and another
fan said very impressed with the
cleanliness of his set clearly a lot of
love and care went into his writing
process watch it while on Edibles and I
loved it watch it again while sober and
it didn't diminish the second time
highly recommend it no pun intended I
definitely understand the people who
don't usually watch clean comedy most of
my favorite specials aren't clean but
with Naper gotsi it's like you don't
even notice it's like it's its own
category his delivery and observations
are so so funny he's able to get the
same amount of laughs as any other
comedian without relying on that extreme
material it's also not like you're
sitting there watching thinking yourself
the whole time damn it I just wish this
guy would swear already that would be
funny though if one day Nate came out
completely unannounced and just did the
filthiest set ever like he went
full-blown Joey Diaz and starts talking
about stinky [__] or something there's
not a lot of people working clean what
was the the mindset there I just was
always going to work clean like it's I
mean I just that's I come from that I'm
you know I'm from the south Christian
like you grew up like that kind of way
like I could only watch clean comics
like it was just how I am and so I just
was never gonna I like it wasn't like a
distinct like I'm gonna do it it was
just being who I was right and who I was
going to be and that kind of Comedy is
the comedy that I watched so it was I
just started that way which helped
because when you start that way you uh
yeah you right I write that way like I
think that way right it's like I really
had like dirty jokes that I wanted to do
or I could do me and Jay would talk
about jokes and we could take and we
could talk do a joke about parking and
mine would and we we could talk about
the same subject but it would go
completely too different yeah right yeah
two different ways a lot of people also
seemed interested in how napargatsu came
up with the title for hello world
usually comedians will put a lot of
effort into naming their specials
because it sets a tone for the show and
lets audience know what they can expect
the last two specials name for gatsu
came out with were titled the Tennessee
kid and the greatest average American
which I feel like matched the energy in
those performances very well for this
latest one hello world Nate said
multiple interviews and it's a nod to
his favorite golfer Tiger Woods who we
actually get to meet in the weeks
leading up to taping the special and
he's like right like you know like now
one of the hardest parts about releasing
a stand-up comedy special is being left
with no material afterwards having to
start from scratch but that doesn't seem
to be too big of a problem for Nate
bargatsi as he's already back on tour
with a new hour of jokes and some ideas
for more yeah I'm trying to write new
stuff now
um
I might have two thought of two things
this morning which was nice
it's nice start to the day
where you're like all right all right
cut something there do y'all know right
away when something's gonna be a good
bit or how many your bits are like this
could go either way this could be 50 50.
this might be bad this might be good I
think if I know I think what I thought
of this morning I thought both were
going to be good then I thought of it a
little longer and I was like one I know
will work
the other one I think I I can make it
works yeah but they both fit into I
already I'm not wrote them down were you
waking up when you thought of them uh
one
like I mean uh I don't want to say it
but it's uh now one's one's very funny
and will work and the other one is uh
does one of them is one of them's its
own joke and one is a thing that will go
in with another joke gotcha okay so it
hit you like like is it a uh just as a
topic or as a whole thing that played
out in your brain one one's a topic
uh and then the other is uh the other is
just an add-on about I talk about my
wife being cheap because that she filled
that Fiji Water and the thing that he
talked about and so it's just like a
little at like I had something this
morning that I was like oh I bet I can
say this yeah and then uh and that one I
you know that was not gonna be its own
kind of thing that's gonna be just kind
of a little ad so it's not like it's
that much but it makes the story or the
thing I'm talking about more colorful
that's it for this video thank you so
much for watching and if this is your
first time here welcome to joke world
this is a channel where we cover the ins
and outs of the stand-up comedy World
basically like a sports center for all
your favorite comedians so if it is your
first time here please consider
subscribing to joke world right now to
join the fastest growing community of
Comedy fans on the internet if this is
not your first time here if you've been
here before if you're old here thanks
for coming back I'm sorry you can't
rejoin the group since you're already in
it but you could subscribe to our second
Channel clip world if you want if you
want more comedy in your life it's just
a suggestion you don't have to subscribe
to clipworld no one's forcing you to
subscribe to clip World Look No One's
Gonna cry themselves to sleep tonight if
you don't subscribe to clip world
seriously I'm fine guys